a farmer in India could not stop monkeys  from destroying his crops so he came up  with an ingenious solution absolutely  true check it out  he painted stripes on his dog so it  would look like a tiger to scare away  monkeys absolutely true painted stripes  on the dog yeah here's the crazy part it  worked according to the news it really  did work he hasn't had a problem with  monkey since now I thought that was a  brilliant idea especially since dogs  make for incredibly cheap employees so  I'd like to announce that as of today I  am firing my Studios human security  guards they're very expensive I'm sorry  I'm letting them go let it cost a lot of  money sorry guys you're very expensive  and I'd like to ask my brand-new  security force to escort you out of the  building  take them away gang  [Applause]  [Applause]  all right we got a great snow tonight  good we got a great show tonight  [Laughter]  except that sound is not fooling anybody